thank god you're here for this because
you're the hall of fame voter i'm not so
you can give us better insight than
anyone about some of these guys out
there and we tripped into this rabbit
hole yesterday with matt ryan because we
talked about what he needs to do to get
to the hall of fame he's closing in on
50 000 passing yards and 300 touchdown
passes and nobody really seems to notice
that matt ryan's had a special career
that is still going strong so let's
consider some other guys that that are
maybe on the fringe right now and that
maybe a super bowl win would give them
that kind of lift that they need to get
the bronze bust in canton and i want to
start
with philip rivers because phillip
rivers has had a hard time standing out
among his peers for a variety of reasons
one of which is he hasn't played in a
super bowl and so clearly hasn't won a
super bowl would that make a huge
difference in your mind if philip rivers
everything he's already done that stays
the same but you throw you know a
special season obviously and a super
bowl win on top of it
i'm glad you started with him mike
because i would have started with him
too you know he does rank in the top 10
and passing touchdowns and passing yards
is just going to continue to climb
because he says he's going to keep
playing and he never seems to get hurt
so the numbers are going to be there but
what else is there as you pointed out
there's no mvp there's no all-pro
he's just played with better
quarterbacks uh within the league at the
time he's played so he's not going to
make an all-decade team even the first
team or the second team
in the time that he played so what else
does he have and i think he has to get
at least one super bowl to be considered
for the hall of fame that's where it
starts now if he can get multiple super
bowls great
and we did talk about him last year at
the beginning of the year and into the
middle of the year for mvp and then it
kind of went away uh late in the year
and he was out of that talk so if you
can get an mvp award and a super bowl i
i
he's there i mean i don't know what else
you want the guy to do but that's asking
a lot
considering his age and how much time he
has left to play
i know there are rules about what you
can and can't talk about as it relates
to what occurs in the room for the
selection committee meeting but is there
any type of standard that gets followed
for the guys who aren't obvious know it
when you see it that guy's in two minute
discussion at most but for a quarterback
is there a formula is there a set of
factors what do you look for to decide
whether or not you think a quarterback
should get in
well i think it's really hard in this
day and age because the passing yards
have changed so much the game has
changed where the passing yards have
gone up and
so it's difficult to compare these guys
against even players from say 15 years
ago or 20 years ago you just can't
because
it is a passing league now and you have
to be able to pass so there has to be
other things to go with that but you
know kurt warner is an example and i
realized kurt warner's
career maybe wasn't as long as some
others maybe he wanted to see more years
in there but every other box he really
checked off and it and by the way it is
the pro football hall of fame it's not
the nfl hall of fame so kurt warner had
a great arena league career if you're
nobody threw that out
but he did
so it is the pro football hall of fame
but you look at how long it took him to
get in and guys like that so there's no
set formula it's you just got to check
off those boxes and and when you look at
a quarterback does he look like a hall
of famer and philip rivers has done some
things where you say yeah this guy's
looked like a hall of famer but i do
think he needs a championship i don't
think he's dan marino
well cam newton looks like the statue
you would put out in front of the hall
of fame i mean he really is an imposing
physical specimen he's won an mvp award
and to me one of the factors is relative
dominance and to stand out among
everyone in this era especially as the
best player in the game is a pretty big
deal
does a super bowl win make the
difference for him or does he have to do
more than that
well i think it's starting to trend him
that way if he can get a super bowl
because you know they went 15-1 the one
year they lost it and were heavy favors
to win it that year and didn't get it
done so i think you have to start
looking at him if he would get that
super bowl win to go with the mvp award
again he's starting to check off some
boxes there and he's not going to finish
probably in the top 10 in passing yards
and passing touchdowns in the
statistical part of it but if he has
those other things i think yeah then
you've got to go okay we've really got
to consider cam newton here and i think
he would be a first ballot hall of famer
because the numbers wouldn't be there
but i do think you talk about him and
eventually he would go in
russell wilson now 30 years of age and
he has that super bowl win back-to-back
super bowl appearances
i i feel like some don't give him the
respect that he deserves they think he's
a running quarterback or they think he's
a quarterback on a run first team
um
it does a second ser does you know if he
retires with one super bowl win and he's
on the track that he's been on is that
enough or does he need that second super
bowl win
he's a guy i think is going to need that
second one just for the reasons you
stated and when we think of great
quarterbacks in this league all decade
players all pros uh
things like that we really don't he
doesn't pop up to most people and i do
think he's a really good player he's
been terrific in this league you know we
had him in the mvp conversation last
year for what he did i don't think he's
had the people on offense that some
other t other quarterbacks have had
around the league but the numbers aren't
going to be there and i think people
some people are going to look at him as
a running quarterback a second super
bowl though
you really start looking at him a lot
harder and and most guys who win two
super bowls and you can point to eli
manning eventually most guys who win two
super bowls get into the hall of fame uh
it may take a while but this guy
probably gets into the hall of fame if
he can win another one
jim plunkett says where's my bronze bust
uh who knows maybe maybe he'll get wet
eventually we'll get in
that 15 that 15 person all in or all out
class that is scheduled for next year
all right let's move away from
quarterback frank gore is a guy who in
my mind already should get in he's
fourth all all-time on the rushing list
he could pass barry sanders this year
this guy quietly has had one of the best
careers in nfl history of any running
back in an era where there aren't many
great running backs so there isn't a lot
of competition if you're looking for a
running back to put in
i don't think it matters to i think
frank gore could walk away today and he
already should get in what are your
thoughts on him
completely agree with you i think frank
gore's done enough to get into the hall
of fame uh probably not a first ballot
guy but i think he'll get in eventually
i say not a first ballot guy because you
look at the running backs uh and some of
them have had to wait in recent years i
think he's a guy who might have to wait
uh but shoot he doesn't look like
the end of his career is anytime close
he just keeps playing and playing and
playing and playing really well and i
think he's going to play really well
again
this season and continue to compile
those yards and i do think he's going to
pass barry sanders for third all time if
he's third all time how do you not put a
guy like that in super bowls no super
bowls however many he has whatever
i just think based on the yards you have
to put that guy in in the hall of fame
there are plenty of former steelers in
the hall of fame who played receiver
they all have championship rings john
starworth lin swan i think heinz ward
has an argument to be made to get in but
antonio brown no super bowl wins one
super bowl appearance as a rookie now
with the raiders
does the super bowl make a difference
for him or does he get in uh based on
his own merit based on his own
production
right now i'd say i need to see a little
bit more a little more longevity from
him maybe a super bowl in there he's
probably going to finish with enough
yards that that you're going to put him
in but if we're talking first ballot and
all guys want to be first ballot guys
you know obviously with t.o that's why
he didn't go to the hall of fame
ceremony he was passed over a couple
times probably shouldn't have been but
if you want to be a first ballot guy you
better check all of the boxes and and
that includes a super bowl so that
certainly would help him go in first
ballot
does jj watt need a super bowl if he
walks away right now i i think i think
he's done enough that he gets in what do
you think
i agree with you i mean there's only one
other guy who's won three defensive
player of the year awards and that's
lawrence taylor and um you know i think
there's probably going to be another guy
out there who's going three four five
and that's aaron donald uh but this guy
is been one of the best defensive
players
in his era he's going to be on the
all-decade team yes i think j.j watts
done enough that if he retires tomorrow
he's going to get into the hall of fame
eventually
but he wouldn't be a first ballot guy
without a super bowl win
uh oh no i think he would be a first
ballot guy i didn't mean it like that at
five he would have to wait us five years
obviously but i think he's a first
ballot guy
now aaron donald you mentioned and i
look i i just feel like no matter what
the guy's on a track right now where
when it's all said and done we may look
back on him as the greatest defensive
player in nfl history is so dominant
he's so disruptive and i continue to be
so stunned that he lasted as long as he
did in the first round of the draft in
2014. uh for him do you agree it doesn't
it's not going to matter whether or not
the rams win a super bowl this guy does
enough that he's going to find a way in
regardless of what his team does
i think you already look at him as one
of the best defensive tackles in nfl
history i mean there's a handful there
and he's one of those guys you go yeah
if if we're gonna make a defensive
tackle if god made a defensive tackle
he's it and he's the guy and he has been
that dominant he's gonna be on the
all-decade team guys when they get on
all decade teams generally go in there
are seven first ballot all decade
players right now who aren't in the hall
of fame and a lot of those guys are
gonna gonna get in on this centennial
class if it's approved uh so we're
looking at most all decade players into
the hall of fame and he's gonna be one
of those guys who's into the hall of
fame as the first ballot guy
a couple of guys who were on the
seahawks that won the super bowl a few
years ago bobby wagner who's still there
richard sherman who's in seattle and i
guess we could throw in earl thomas as
well
i you know
is there going to be a representation of
the legion of boom or that defense
generally in canton when it's all said
and done or do they need to do more post
2013
a lot of those guys are really good at
their positions again when you go back
and look at the all decade teams i think
some of them are probably going to be on
there i mean we're into what the last
year of of this decade and and so that's
an important thing when that all decade
team comes out the players on that list
when you start seeing them those are the
guys who are probably going to be hall
of famers when when it's all said and
done when they retire five years after
they retire
they're going to go into the hall of
fame and a lot of those seahawks players
because they've been the best defense in
football for a really long time or were
for a really long time i think a lot of
those guys are going to be under
consideration uh come hall of fame time
when when their names up and i think
they're going to be on the finalists
list and they're going to be discussed
and probably a couple two three of those
guys get in now it's hard to put a lot
in when you only win one super bowl you
look at the tampa buccaneers for as good
as their defense was for so long uh you
know the john lynches and the simeon
rice's and the rendez barbers are still
having to wait because you go how many
guys do you put in off of that defense
derrick brooks is in and and uh
the warren sapps in so how many
defensive guys do you put in so that's
the only thing i i caution with there on
that seahawks defense but they should
have two that's what they would say they
did everything in their power to win a
second super bowl it was the offensive
play call that prevented that from
happening at the end of super bowl 49
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports